- Every entrepreneur
who's listening right now
knows one thing that I know.
That your business is your second child,
is your third child, is your fourth child.
I have no idea how many
children everyone has.
That's the answer, because
I'm treating my business
like a parent.
You know, it's almost
like your garden, right?
Those tomatoes are gonna
come out, that's you.
With with the macro.
I can't control mother nature,
just like I can't control the world.
But I can maximize my tomatoes this year
if I do good behavior.
And that's how I think
about my businesses.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(soft music)
- What interests you about
Sweden and business here?
- Couple things, one, you know,
one of the great advantages
of my life is that I was born
in the former Soviet Union
and so, and then my first business,
which was a family business,
which obviously means
I love it so much like a child
was in the wine business.
So, the amount of time I
spent in France and Italy,
Spain, so as an American
and I think, you know,
obviously, I moved to
the US when I was three
and for like any place, there's things
that you like or don't like about things.
But obviously, I'm a proud American
and have a, especially as an entrepreneur
is you can imagine, there's a lot of pride
in the framework of
entrepreneurship in America,
which is at the top of class.
On the flip side, one of the
things that's a shortcoming,
in my opinion of Americans
is they become very insular
because America is such
a big part of the world
and they don't travel,
they don't have context
for a lot of other cultures or people.
My circumstances have allowed me that.
And so, that's amazing.
Leads me to my answer.
Sweden, which, this is probably my seventh
or eighth trip here,
'cause I've done a lot of speaking here
and some business here.
In a lot of ways, I
believe Sweden is a preview
to America in 50 to 75 years.
I think the maturity of Europe as a whole
and then specifically in the Nordics
and then specifically to Sweden,
my number one thing that
interests me about Sweden is
I kind of think it's, I guess
I almost think sometimes
that I'm looking at the
place that my grandchildren
are gonna live in if they
decide to stay in America.
And what I mean by that is it's obviously
an older country for that
point, but there's a,
there an incredible thing that Sweden has
that I admire, which is socially,
it's so outrageously
progressive in comparison
to the macro world.
However, it's not as
foofy foofy or soft or
becomes the cliche, you
know, ideological thing.
There's still an incredible
level of practicality,
innovation, entrepreneurship.
I guess ultimately, I admire the balance
of the business culture
human infrastructure
and so, yeah, I've always
felt, you know, it's funny.
I like to keep things basic.
But we spelled good when I was here.
- What excites you when you look at
the workplace and the business?
Because you do have a
little bit an idea of
how things work here.
- Yeah, I mean, (mumbles) I,
it's an interesting question.
And I'll tell you why.
I'm incredibly I'll use optimistic.
I'm incredibly optimistic
to where companies can go
both on how they do
marketing and communications
and how they treat employees
and deploy culture.
So, though I think there is a
lot of progressive thinking,
in the marketplace, I do
still think the nature
of a corporate structure and the nature
of being a big, let's say a big company
still requires you to hit
numbers and every 90 days
and so, you know, ironically,
in the bigger businesses, call
it the 100 biggest businesses
in the country,
it doesn't look so so so different
than other parts of the world.
I think as you go down the scale,
I do think that there's,
I think on the coast of America,
on the entrepreneurial
level, there is a little bit
of a potential for burnout
or too much overworking
or working for the sake of working
that I think is a little
more balanced here
from the startups that
I've interacted with.
And so, much are the same
in the top 100 companies
compared to the world, which is much more
to do on culture and people and marketing.
And on the entrepreneurial
front, a little bit more balanced
than I see in other places.
- Well, if you were
recruited as a CEO of one of
the big Swedish, say, media companies,
'cause you have a few, what
would people experience
that was different in your
leadership, do you think?
Compared to a Swedish, because
Swedes, Swedish managers
are not well known to be hard and firm and
they're like, more people oriented.
- Yeah, you know, I actually think
that's an interesting thing.
So, I remember you're doing
something interesting here,
which is you're using the data
that you have in the macro.
So, I think one thing that
you'll find fascinating
is somebody who knows a little bit
about my personality online.
It was funny, I was smiling towards David.
I would argue that I am the softest
manager at my company and I'm the soft,
I would argue that I am softer
than 95% of the managers
in Sweden.
Even though, on the
internet, I'm a very outward
aggressive, American for
an American personality.
Because that's me as a communicator
in content on the internet.
The way I manage my people
is very very very different.
I would argue that the
43 year old version of me
as an executive has had to
work over the last decade
on radical candor.
And so, you know, but on the flip side,
what I would tell you is,
I think I create at my
best and I like to think
I'm heading to my best, I
create very safe environments.
If you can get your employees to feel safe
they can be their best,
however, I do think
that some of the advanced laws
in trying to create safety
and balance, also creates
entitlement and softness.
- Can you describe what a soft leader is?
You used the word soft.
I use the word soft too.
- Yeah, I was following your lead
but I think what we're saying
and I'm sure everybody who's listening,
and by the way, I'm honored
to be the first English guest.
I care about people's
emotions and happiness
and overall livelihood, not
what they produce for me
in the short term as an
employee of my company.
I don't know what else to say.
I care more about, I look at
our voluntary retention numbers
10 times more than I look
at our profit margin.
- And
- I'm an HR driven CEO
not a CFO driven CO.
Here's why.
I want to create clarity for
everybody who's listening.
'Cause I'm playing forever.
I own my businesses.
I'm, so for me, I can do
things that lead to retention
and a real relationship because
I'm not held accountable
to Wall Street or a
public market or a board
or, I'm so money hungry
that I want a yacht.
And I believe most are.
- Mm, do you, because you
do have a lot of people
interacting with you.
Can you talk a little bit how you scale
that personal connection,
your ability to see,
the person that you work with,
the person behind the employee.
How do you scale that when you have 1000s
of people around you?
- So we have a 1000 in
our ecosystem at VaynerX
all the companies I
have under VaynerMedia.
I do micro macro.
Micro, I have a very
aggressive open door policy.
I meet.
- Meaning?
- Meaning any single
employee that works for me
that requests a meeting, gets a meeting.
I sometimes when they
don't take me up on that
because they're scared or
they don't wanna bother me,
I'm aggressive in creating
meetings with people
to check in, so, I love people.
That's why I well in social.
Because that was a scaled version of it.
And it's why I do well right
now with the five of us.
And so, I'm very aggressive
101 meetings, very.
And that's micro.
And then macro.
I follow a stunning amount of
my employees on social media,
I read the Slack channels to
watch what their talking about.
- Slack is a like a
- For everybody who's
listening,
- internet very much
the opposite of email.
- Yeah, I mean, though I think
it's just like email in the end.
To your point, it was built to
be a better version of email
and G-Chat.
The problem is no tool,
even a good one like Slack
can stop humans from
being wildly inefficient.
- So what you're saying is
you know things about them
and that's what you build
relationships on?
- I care and have the intent
and believe in the value
of knowing them as human
beings to do what I think
is my requirement, which is to put them
in the best position to succeed.
I apologize, I'm gonna
give you an anecdote.
I was in the London office yesterday.
I forced somebody to leave the media team
and now work in project management.
A very junior employee, she's been with us
for 18, 24 months.
I, from the tippy top all the
way down to the London office
on the micro media team,
demanded as a dictator
to move her from media to
project management on two things.
One, she was not having
a good relationship
with her managers.
And it was neither of their faults
after I investigated personally.
And two, through the series
of her communicating with me,
I thought that she had
tremendous organizational skills
and I saw her yesterday
and she was so happy.
I'm a CEO who happens to
also have tens of millions
of followers on social
media, does public speaking,
I'm here for things like this.
I'm stretched incredibly thin
and yet I was able to
execute against that.
And this is not me saying it
for everybody who's listening
to think I'm good or,
it speaks to intent.
Either, let me save
everybody a lot of time
on this incredible mission
that this podcast is on.
Either a company is about its people
or a company is about money.
Any company that is publicly traded
or has a board that has
control over the CEO
she or he has to pander
to something outside
of their employees.
Independence, whether in the
micro or at massive scale
at least gives you the chance
to be employee centric.
- So, how did you communicate that to her
and how did she receive it?
- Well, it was in the
conversation I was having to her
about her not being happy.
And then also double checking
and hearing from her managers
that maybe it's her fault.
Was data I was collecting and
then I came over to the top
with HR and finance and
just requested the move.
So, I didn't even communicate to her
that I was doing the move.
It just happened.
She, when I saw here, I'm
not sure she knows how much
or how little I had to do with it
and I'm not really in the
business of getting stars
on my shirt but I'm really happy about it.
And whether it works out
or not, I have no idea
but the moral of the story for everybody
one more time, especially if
you're listening right now
and you have the power.
You know, something I said yesterday
to the London office was
everything in VaynerMedia
is my fault.
There's 1000 things wrong right now.
There's eight to 80 people
that are responsible for that
but at the end of the
day, I hired and empowered
those eight to 80.
If you are lucky enough to have control
and you're listening right now.
And if you're listening to
this, you care about the things
that we care about, please
look yourself in the mirror
and realize you're the
one that has the ability
to make the change that you
ideologically believe in.
- What do you mean it your fault?
- That's what I mean.
I mean, if our, if the
snacks in the kitchen stink,
if we lost a client, if
the micro production team
in the LA office is not working well,
in the end, every single thing
in the company is my fault
because I have the power to hire and fire
every human that is actually
creating that truth.
- Somebody else would say
you're micro managing.
- Yeah, I think, I think
I could be micro managing
in the philosophy but you know, I think
if you speak to anybody
who's been a direct report
of mine over the last
decade, the biggest argument
and issue they have is,
I'm not involved enough.
I am in the bat phone business.
What that means, since I'm
using a Batman reference
and I'm not sure how
big Batman is in Sweden,
or now that we're going
global in the podcast,
I'm in the business of
being in responding to.
So, I have no interest in micro managing
until there is an issue at hand.
And so, yes, somebody could
say that philosophically.
But in actual practitioner-ship
or operational,
the way this energy that
I'm speaking about manifests
in reality is you're
only putting your finger
in the hole that it biggest
in your boat at that moment.
Which means there's a lot of boat left
for those people to run.
- So, just to give us more
insight of you as a leader,
when you have those one
one one conversations,
your doors is open, someone's coming
to talk about a challenge or an idea,
if you could describe how do
you prefer to use that time?
How do you empower people?
What do spend that time with them?
- And some of them are five minutes
just for clarity for everybody.
I don't have a preference.
And I don't think it's my
place to have a preference
on how it's spent.
I have a preference that it happens
'cause it creates
context of a relationship
with me and an employee
which begins the process
of creating a safe environment to allow us
to have actual conversations.
So, by the nature of the
framework, it's already happening.
As far as how it's spent,
you would be fascinated.
People use it to vent,
people use it to actually
have change be made,
people use it to tell me
something they've always
wanted to tell me.
I don't really have a preference.
My preference is that when they leave
and they go home and they
tell their best friend
or their spouse and if they ask,
how did it go with Gary today?
I know you were meeting with him.
My preference is that
it's a positive reaction,
that they don't feel
that I, my number one,
the only thing I don't want to happen
is that they say, eh, he just
does that to check the box.
It was a waste of time.
- Then you're disappointed.
- Of course.
I'm in the business of
providing value for the people
that work for me, so, I
don't have a preference
of how they wanna use it,
even if it's just a check in
to you know, I had one
recently with an employee
that's been with us for seven years.
And she's been crushing
it and we haven't talked
in maybe two and a half years.
And it was just, I think
she just needed to feel
for five minutes that I did
have my hands in everything
AKA I don't have my hands in anything
but I'm aware of quite a
bit, if not most things
and her hearing that where
I could speak to detail
on things that she started talking about,
gave her confidence that she
still works for an organization
that has a CEO that has care and intent
and isn't living in a
ivory tower and isn't naked
with no clothes and that
is my agenda at all times.
- Because you as a person
cannot scale infinitely,
you have other managers.
- Of course.
- And
I'm just thinking how
can you, you talk about
how you foster a relationship
that engages both
employees and customers?
'Cause I see this being
outside of the company
was you, this is the style
your company has towards
customers as well, seeing them as people.
How do you foster that kind of leadership?
- By holding people
accountable that have clout
in doing the same.
- Clout means influence and
- Yes
- Ability to change things.
- Yes.
It is imperative that
the 50 most senior people
in my company have somewhere
between an 80 to 99%
of this in their soul as well.
I can't ask them to be 100% of
the same intent that I have.
As much as possible and then it is my job
back to the statement of
everything is your fault,
when you have control, it's my job
to make the tough decision
when somebody no longer
is allowed to be in our company
when they don't embody that mission.
- I have a question for you
because I've been thinking
about how one handles managers
who are very engaged in their job
but do, who do not manage to be engaging
vis-a-vis their colleagues
'cause that do happen that,
you have people who are
like living for their work
but they can't handle their colleagues.
- If it's a neutral, I
try to make them work out.
If it's a detriment to
the other employees,
they can no longer be there.
I value how the other boys
and girls feel about you
over anything else, over the skill,
over how much money you
bring in to the organization,
over how great and passionate
you are about your craft.
If you are the most
passionate about your craft,
but the 23 people that are surrounding you
are miserable, because you're a curmudgeon
or worse, not a nice
person, it won't work out.
If you're neutral, and
there are those leaders.
I have leaders in my
organization who are great
at their craft, who are
indifferent and neutral as leaders.
When things in the macro
are good, it's no problem.
It's when things are tough,
where you need wartime generals
so, for me right now
because things in the macro
are so good, those executives can continue
to navigate and you try to
build moats around them,
you try to build them
up, you try to figure out
if it's a personality
trait or if it's something
they've never been trained on.
And but but if it's detrimental
to the way you framed up the question,
there's just, there's no
person that is more valuable
than the culture at hand.
- We need more innovation,
we need to speed up
the rate of change in the world.
And I'm curious about your perspective on
what's what kind of leadership will foster
a more rapid rate of change?
- Freedom.
This is my actual issue
with Europe, actually.
That one of the reasons
innovation is difficult
is heavy handing restrictions.
This is where an American
business point of view
of deregulation and openness,
I think goes too far
because people are actually money greedy.
But in real life, having more freedom
to do things matters.
How do you speed up things?
Less rules.
Less process.
How do you speed up things?
Less fear.
You know, so you know, this is something
that has been my calling
card for 20 years.
And it is out of, it is
out of complete and utter
lack of fear, complete and
utter disdain for process
that is in the mix for
the sake of process.
Obviously some process is needed.
And this is ultimately
was the first reason
I got into culture besides having good DNA
about liking people.
It was that I understood
that if people were motivated
and excited, that great
things would happen
versus fearful and political.
The type of leader that will create this
is one that really focuses
on those three things
that I just mentioned.
- And also you mentioned the ability
to create a safe environment.
- It's so important.
- And I think that
is so beautiful when you say that.
Because it's not something
we often talk about.
We don't talk about safe because
we think it hinders change.
- You know, it's funny.
Again, David, D-Rock who films me
and post produces a lot of my content
and has been on my team for a long time
and for clarity everybody,
I put out a lot of content.
I'm actually starting to wonder.
I actually may be, and
this is a funny statement
especially if you don't know who I am.
You might find this
audacious so I apologize.
But I'm actually quite proud of this.
I don't know if it's true.
But I think it might be.
I legitimately might be the human being
that puts out the most
daily content at scale
on the entire internet.
I am putting put 40, 50, 60
pieces of meaningful content
on LinkedIn, Facebook,
Twitter, dada, nonetheless,
where am I going with this?
Most of this is organized
through one text thread
with 30 people on it.
I have 30 people now who are on my team
that produce Gary V content, right?
Strategy, media, creative.
There was something that was post, I mean,
there has been multiple
things posted recently
because we have a lot of junior members
that we're onboarding to do things
where the junior member,
the most junior member
and Maha, I wanna make sure
you're paying attention to this
because I don't know
this is caught your radar
'cause I know you are on the list too now.
- Gary's calling his assistant Maha.
- No, my boss Maha.
Literally, this 30 person thread and I saw
one of the most junior
people posted a podcast
that hadn't been edited yet
and had sensitive information
and was comfortable enough
to post in the entire thread
hey Gee, my bad.
Now, here's what's important.
And I want everybody
listen very carefully.
Most junior person, pretty big mistake
like in the scheme of like
I mean, not in real life
but in the business world,
says in front of everybody
and says it to me and it wasn't
a fun thing to deal with.
Couple things.
One, that's creating a world
where there isn't fear.
- It's a barometer of
how safe the person is.
- Thank you but I have
goosebumps and I'll tell you
why I have goosebumps and
this is very exciting for me
to say in Sweden and in
the Nordics and in Europe
and in the world.
There was also a 1% to
5% energy behind the text
of a little bit of fear.
Or let me say it a different
world, because I don't
actually think it was fear but I'm trying
to make a point here.
There was accountability.
There he, 'cause it's the truth, knows
that I might have texted
him off chain and fired him.
And that I could do that.
And that
- 'Cause you're the boss?
- Yeah, and oh by the way because the laws
don't require me to give him six months,
I mean this is important because
- You emphasized on the
difference the US and
- Europe.
- And I'll tell you why.
Because I think Europe is so close
and it's just a couple tweaks.
I don't think the US has it right.
I don't think Europe has it right
and by the way, this is my personal way
that I wanna run my world.
I'm not saying I'm right.
I'm trying to bring value here for people
to make their own decisions.
- But it creates a nerve
in your organization.
- And it's not, it's a nerve based on,
it's not that I, I'm a
softy, I established early.
I really am, like my
CFO is here, he's like,
we don't fire fast enough.
It creates entitlement but
the fact that it could happen
creates accountability.
It is not a nerve that is,
so, it's safety with responsibility.
- And they are clear rules of the game.
- Yeah, it's just like,
it's that the rules
don't overly protect you
form lack of execution
or ability but nonetheless,
I appreciate you
jumping on this, because
it is probably the thing
I'm most, let me rephrase.
It is one of the things I'm very proud of.
And one of the things that I
wanna talk a lot more about
over the next 30 years of my life
which is I create very
very safe environments,
which I now believe leads
to incredibly good behavior
for the people that play
within that framework.
And by the way, I actually
believe that that has
to do with a lot of the best,
'cause we're using that theme here
in this call, obviously, I
think that has a lot to do
with some of the best
nations in the world too.
You know.
You know, as an American citizen,
I've traveled the world my whole life.
Sometimes in not the greatest places
and I've never been
fearful because I know that
those places know that
they can't kidnap me.
- What he's lead you
to this, do you think?
- Actually.
- 'Cause it's not
a view that everybody
holds who are on top.
- Running my one businesses
as if they were my children themselves,
thus having to ask deeper questions
than just financial success.
I, I'll just add one more thing.
And I know you wanna move on.
'cause I'm getting a
little long winded here.
But I'm excited because I
love this subject matter.
When every entrepreneur
who's listening right now
knows one thing that I know.
That's your business is your second child,
is your third child, is your fourth child.
I have no idea how many
children everyone has.
That's the answer, because
I'm treating my business
like a parent.
- Or your spouse.
- Yeah, but even more like a parent.
And I'll tell you why.
With a spouse, or a partner,
that's a lateral relationship
whereas a child or a business,
you are in charge of it.
You're grooming it.
You know, it's almost
like your garden, right?
Those tomatoes are gonna come out.
That you with with the macro.
I can't control mother nature
just like I can't control the world.
But I can maximize my tomatoes this year
if I do good behavior.
And that's how I think
about my businesses.
- What are the
- That was interesting.
- Weak signs of your leadership?
- I do not like negativity.
And so in my early years, since
I started running companies
right from the beginning,
my historic vulnerability
that I continue to work on
and is far in a better place
than it used to be is in
my unbelievable disdain
for confrontation and negativity,
I wasn't canderous enough
and would surprise people
when I would fire them.
And or also created a level of entitlement
which usually led to the firing
because they weren't
getting negative feedback.
They were just getting
positive reinforcement.
- And suddenly something happened.
- And they became delusional,
no, and unfortunately,
it wasn't that suddenly
something happened,
for the last three years,
they've always been bad
at these three things.
I just don't focus on negatives.
I focus on positives.
They don't hear anything about it
and then they get called into the meeting
probably thinking they're
about to get a raise
because four weeks ago,
I gave them a high five
about something they do do well.
And then I'm like, hey Jan.
Hey Rick.
You know, we're gonna have to
talk about yo not being here
and they would be flabbergasted
and I would defend my actions to myself
in my 20s and early 30s
on their delusional, how do they not know?
Couldn't they tell?
But but a lot of people don't
deploy the self awareness
that I was gifted with.
It's not, you know, and more importantly,
employees always have
other side, like everybody,
there's always two sides to a story
so over the last three or four years
and I'll tell you that my brother, AJ
who was 22 years old
when he became my partner
at VaynerMedia 10 years ago.
He is far, you know, he's a good balance.
My dad is over critical and only focused
on the negative.
So I think I naturally was over positive
but then being in the
same company with him
in a father son team, I
almost had to be 100% positive
to offset 100% negative
and that's the truth.
- So, you were a little dishonest.
You didn't want to really
- I hate that it's, I'm smiling
'cause I hate that it's, yes.
I was a little dishonest
and a lot dishonest.
I would not fully articulate
my thoughts to my employees.
I would try to grow so
much that it could hide
all their shortcomings
but then inevitably,
as my companies grew,
you know, it's one thing
when you have a family
liquor store business
and you have 10 employees,
you can manage all of them.
When I started getting to
80 and 100 in that business,
other people had to manage and that's when
my vulnerabilities exposed themselves
because I didn't recognize
what I was actually doing.
And now with Vayner, with
1,000, it's become even bigger
because even the quality,
let's call it what it is,
the executives at VaynerMedia
are a different quality
than a stock boy in a liquor store
when they're 19 at a liquor store.
So, I've learned a lot.
My, I've learned a lot.
My brother started that process
because I admired his level
of candor even as a kid
because it's a natural skill for him.
And then and then five or four years ago,
Vayner was getting big, we
were at four or 500 people.
I was carrying so much of the financial
and emotional burden, back
to micromanaging in the macro
that I could see because
I was a practical operator
that there was a financial vulnerability,
that if I wasn't gonna get
more out of the top 50 people,
that all trickled.
I also didn't like the way our
company was being structured
towards, going towards the world I saw,
which is a bigger impact
around the volume of creative
needed to be put out.
So, we, for the first
time after going from 30
to 400 people in three years.
We did a 35 person layoff.
The company lost its mind.
The over reaction, the stuff that I,
and if you've been listening carefully,
the stuff that I like to
take subtle digs about,
I so admire you're up
but there's subtle things
I dig about, ironically,
I was being hypocritical.
I was doing the same
thing in my four walls.
Probably why I've always
loved these places
because I'm probably, as a
human, I'm probably way more
Sweden than I am Soviet
Russia or even America.
So, it's interesting.
That was a really important
moment in my career.
'Cause a couple things.
One, I'm gonna talk
tomorrow about entitlement
and I'm gonna put pressure
on the parents in the room
saying, look, if you've
been paying for everything
for your kid and then at 22
you tell them you're cut off,
they're not prepared.
And then they're gonna be mad at you.
And we look, as outsiders
being mad at the kid,
you entitled brat.
You think you're entitled
to $2,000 a month
allowance from your parents.
But you've trained them to not be capable.
That's what I did at Vayner
and it was a painful year
on our culture and it's been
a teaching moment for me.
- Are you more authentic now?
Because you said you
- 100%.
'cause it surprised me when you say,
I used the word dishonest,
which was not fair.
We should have used the word non authentic
because you say that
you love meeting people.
You say you like to
- I do.
- build relationships.
- I do
And I think authenticity
is kind of the fuel
for that process, so, you're taking away
an ingredient in that relationship.
- It was
- By not being completely honest.
- 100%.
Now, what you can imagine, though,
is the recipient of that
lack of authenticity
enjoyed the shit out of it.
Because it's just positive reinforcement
instead of critical feedback.
So, both parties were quite
happy for the majority
of that relationship.
It was only when I had to
deal with the realities
of the merit of running an organization
that has consequences that
I even had to address it.
Yeah, it's, it's not my favorite part.
As you could imagine, one of the reasons
I have such a big audience in the world
is I can be 100% authentic with them
because I can't analyze the
truth after I engage with them
because they move on to their lives
and I'm not sitting there living.
Unlike VaynerMedia
where after I tell Carol
that she's the sweetest
sweetheart of all time,
that her strategy work
is incredible, right,
that she's a sunshine in the office,
that she's always
responsible and hard working,
and she leaves, meanwhile
I know that clients
aren't happy with her or she's incapable
of upselling a client, which
is becoming detrimental
to the business.
You know,
- Your feedback
wasn't very helpful then.
- You're right.
And so, what's really fun
about being a human being,
especially one that's probably
gifted with a lot of things
that do make them
successful, is going through
the course of your career
and deploying humility
to understanding your own shortcomings
no matter how sweet they
taste for both parties
and then adjusting and I often have said
that the 43 year old version of me,
even though the 25 year old version of me
thought he was gonna be great
and thought he was naturally talented,
the experience matters and
it's why I value experience.
- It's great getting older.
- It's great getting older and so,
I'm proud of A, getting
to a place in my life
where I could recognize it and address it
and, by the way, I'm still
not all the way there.
You know, if we're calling
on a scale of one to 10,
I used to be a one or two on this.
I'm probably a five to
7.5 on this right now
but I'm on my way to
being an eight or nine.
I'll never be a 10.
It's not naturally in me.
Not only am I proud that I have been able
to move from zero and
one to five to seven.
I'm proud that I'm in a place
where I can articulate it
for 10 minutes on a podcast
knowing that it can help somebody
who naturally is in a juxtaposition
similar to where I was.
You know, in the past.
- In order to grow,
what kind of feedback do
you ask your colleagues for?
- I try to create a very safe environment.
It's funny, we have an
incredible new head of,
credible, I'm outrageously optimistic
of the incredible woman I've just hired
to run the London office.
And yesterday, I sat down with her
and I spent 20 minutes
just making her feel safe.
Hey, Sarah, you can tell, hey, Sarah.
This is literally verbatim,
hey Sarah, 'cause she has a big Rolodex,
she's a big get for us,
she has her own client base
I go, look, if somebody
reaches out to you tomorrow,
and they're like Sarah,
we wanna talk to you
about VaynerMedia, but do not bring Gary.
We don't like his brashness,
you need to tell me.
That doesn't hurt my feelings.
I'm thrilled.
That I'm unemotional,
whatever's the right interest
to the business.
You don't need to micromanage me, right.
Or
- What is the one
question, what is the
one piece of feedback
you're most curious to get?
- The truth.
- Yeah, but about what?
- Whatever the hell is in front of them.
Running an operation is not a education
or philosophical exercise.
What do I want?
I want to know exactly what is an issue
operationally, right this second, to you,
from your perspective, in
you running your world.
And how can I help?
- Feedback on your leadership.
What are you most curious about?
- The reverse of that coin.
What can I do to put you in
the best position to succeed?
Are you looking to talk to me more often?
Are you talking to me less?
Do you need some leeway
with your financial PNL?
Do you need me to rah rah the troops.
Do you want me to go talk
to the most senior client
because the client that you work with,
which is the second most senior client,
is giving you a very difficult time?
I am in the ambulance
firefighting emergency doctor,
bat phone business.
I am only built to act in
helping for you to succeed
within this framework.
- It's kind of massive that
somebody says that to you.
I would be almost moved if
my manager said that to me.
- And I believe when you
look at our organization,
the people that have been with
me for seven, eight years,
the people that are winning
the most really see it.
And the people that don't,
hear it and think it's a
think they deploy
cynicism that I just wanna
hear myself speak and it's an ideology
and that I won't actually
do it because what's amazing
about employees is how
many and this, by the way,
I'm gonna set this up on the podcast.
I'm actually very excited to say this.
I actually think for all the
very thoughtful conversations
we just had, I can feel
it in my body right now.
This piece of content may be the piece
that brings the most value.
I am blown away by how many employees
have made judgements
on their organizations
without trying to address it.
The amount of my employees
that come into my office
on year three call my bluff
finally to address something.
I address it in 48 hours within a month,
whatever the issue is.
They come back and say, I
can't believe you did it.
And then give me 31 other
things that happened
in the first 36 months of their tenure
but they decided to be cynical.
They vet with their friend at a beer,
they talk about it in the girls' bathroom.
They tell their mother,
but they never told me
or the organization.
It is the great shortcoming of
employees in our world today.
My friends, call the company's bluff.
Call the bluff.
I mean, if you haven't gone to HR
or the CEO, or however
your world is structured,
well then you have no legs to stand on
that the company stinks.
If you have and they have
delivered, vent away.
But until you call the bluff,
then you're just complaining
because you like to complain.
- Or be the change, be the
change you want to see.
Be the change maker yourself
and hold yourself
accountable for that change.
- Let's talk about that
because I understand
why you're saying that.
You'll appreciate where
I'm going with this.
I have a lot of empathy for that person
on the other line right now listening
because there's only so much you can do.
Like, that's just the truth.
And people always ask me,
Gary I wanna impact people
the way you do, change the
world, these very heady things.
I'm like, well, just do it for one person.
It's action.
Everybody, people love
to ideate or pontificate.
But they don't do.
And so for me, this is a game about doing.
So, yes, be that change but be that change
as somebody who does it
within what they can control.
You know, you knocking
on the door of the CEO
and demanding XYZ is very
cute but you're not sitting
with all the context.
And so, yeah.
- Because this is the engagement podcast,
can you try narrow down what
is the number one driver
of engagement in the workplace?
- The ability to listen.
The number one driver of
engagement is the macro
and then the individual employees
that make up the company's,
ability to actually listen.
Man, gosh, I really
- So, cultivating
our ability to listen.
- The end
- As employees,
as managers, is a very
important focus going forward
for you and your organization.
- It's the only thing I think about.
If you think about the,
just to create some
levels of clarity here for everybody,
the, to, the ability to engage
and be engaged in things
of that nature completely started
with the seed of being heard.
You know, somebody being
heard is completely different
than somebody who feels
they are note heard.
- That's also what research shows.
- Is that true?
Good.
That's makes me feel good.
Yeah.
- To have to be seen and
to have the opportunity
or possibility to influence the
- The outcome.
- situation.
So that you're not trapped.
- Nothing makes me more excited
than when a junior employee
comes, gives a recommendation
and then seven months later,
it actually becomes true
and the reach out to me
and they never think it was them.
Hey, Gary, it's Sarah Thomson here.
You know, we met seven months ago
you know, just saw the announcement,
or just saw this or this just happened.
You know I'm sure it wasn't me
and you probably don't
remember that I asked you
but I'm so glad it's happening.
And then me on a flight
at 1:30 in the morning.
Dear Sarah, it happened because
you walked into my office.
I heard you, I thought you might be right.
I investigated, we did it, da da da da.
It's one of my favorite parts of my job.
- In your view how aware are
the average business leaders
of the correlation between
employee engagement
and profitability?
- Nonexistent.
Because CFO's are too
literal in Excel sheet
and 90%, if not 99% are not
deploying emotional intelligence
above their financial intelligence.
And they are spreadsheet basics.
And
- Do we need new KPI's?
- Yes.
- How do we clarify this corelation
because it is there,
research shows it's there.
You've seen it, others have seen it.
- Research oftentimes and
reporting doesn't penetrate
a cliche CFO.
You know, no matter what you and I,
I come and talk from personal experience.
Somebody else comes from an
academic point of view on this.
Shows dear CFO, the, you know,
you are wasting 4.9
million a year of people
sitting there and crying and not working
and if you had better engagement,
you know, I know that
to be true in my bones.
In my bones, I know that a proper culture
creates a scenario where
people have better output
in the time that they deploy.
I know that is intuitive human.
But if you're, but now
let's have some empathy
in the other direction.
If you're the CFO of Ericsson
and you have to report numbers
and you have to report
numbers every 90 days,
it gets very hard for you
to make the investment.
Let's play this out.
Okay, so, Rick and Susan
hear us and they deploy,
they're bought it, they
believe in you and I.
What happens next?
Well, you have to start putting in money
to put into programs.
You have to put in money
to put into human beings
that rev up the culture.
They all of a sudden we
ask the CFO who's looking
every 90 days on a whim in their mind,
'cause it's not
mathematically quantitatable,
no matter what our report show,
they have to pour money
in to this for the hope
that later, it pays dividends.
- It's called investment.
- I've heard.
People don't invest.
- So should we
- People, real quick
- Go to the owners?
To the shareholders?
- Shareholders like, we live
in a financially driven world
in the business world and in all of that,
is all fine, to your point,
I think this is a financial question too.
There's just a word that I left out.
We live in 2019, in a short
term financial ecosystem.
Start up founders wanna sell
their company in two years
to a bigger company.
Everybody is so impatient
to financial success
both in the big companies
and one one off entrepreneurs
that people are not making
investment into long term health
of their organizations
and the shareholders
don't care either.
I mean,
- But you're an expert
in communication.
You know how to change, how to
capture other people's minds
and hearts.
What is your advice to
(mumbles), who's pay engagement,
who's really trying to put
this question on the agenda
of the executive teams
of large organizations?
That there is a positive
correlation between
high employee engagement,
innovation, profitability
and also just health numbers,
number of days sick, or et cetera.
- So, the way in the macro of all this,
it's basically what
I'm doing for a living.
The reason I'm putting out so much content
as a human and collecting
so much popularity
is to deploy it against better behavior
both professional and personally.
In the micro of your question,
anybody who's listening right now,
you will be 100% historically correct
if you beat this drum.
You will be 100% historically correct
that employee engagement
leads to financial rewards.
I have no idea where,
when you hear me say that
on how convinced you are right now.
Are you a 90%, a 50%?
My one take on it is
that you will be 1005%
historically correct.
No different than the people, I'm sure,
in the 90s and 60s who were
yelling that cigarettes
were bad for you when that
was still being debated
became historically correct.
I have no idea if the 89
year old who was doing that
feels amazing about this,
indifferent, I don't know.
But that would be my plea.
Which is if you're like me, wired like me,
the ambition to be
correct and the enjoyment
of bringing positivity and practicality
to our society and then
being revered and admired
for that truth when it plays out,
if you're lucky enough
to have that wiring,
please see it through and
keep beating this drum.
Because it is you that
ultimately makes those changes.
- In your view, who is responsible
for your engagement at work?
Is it you as the employee
- Both
- Or your boss.
- 50 50.
- Mm hmm, and you you're also firm believe
that that anybody could build
their own unique business
and I watch a lot of your
podcasts and you number one
piece of advice for
succeeding is work hard.
How do you manage that with
sustained engagement over time
in a healthy way?
- Because my number one
statement is actually be happy.
I just need to, no different
than when I realized
five years ago that I
needed to do a better job
in radical candor, I've
realized over the last 10 years
you saying earlier that you weren't being,
there was a level of dishonesty
made my stomach go down, right?
And but I'm about to go to a point.
You right now saying your
number one piece of advice
is work hard made my
stomach go down further.
No, now listen.
Let me clarify this.
I believe in work ethic
like nobody's business.
I believe that work ethic
is an enormous variable
of success.
And controllable, which is powerful.
However, my, you know, through the years,
what I've not done as good of a job
though I've sprinkled it, though I've done
unique pieces of content about it,
though my second book was
called the Thank You Economy,
though in my first book,
Crush It, I speak about this,
the reason this is a
very easy answer for me
is the way you sustain it is loving it.
It doesn't become being a workaholic
when you're doing your hobby.
The reason I started telling people that,
the reason I, you know, when
people hear anybody can do it,
they're like, eh, Gary, this is the, you.
It's I'm like, no no, take a step back.
We now live in an internet world
where the cost of entry is zero
and every one of us
who's listening right now
has a passion whether that
fishing, fashion, hair coloring,
drinking wine, sport,
I believe that anybody
can start the process of creating content
around something they're passionate about,
which will always do better than something
you're not passionate about.
And that over time, that
may lead to something
that can pay you 30, 40,
80,000 euros or dollars a year
or eventually, millions if
you're ultimately talented.
Are you willing to live a humble life
that makes 47,000 a year only
speaking about blueberry jam?
But you're happy?
Is my pressure and question.
And so,
- It's a great question.
- To me, it's something that I'm pushing
more clarity around, which
is I want you to be happy.
- And accountable.
- Of course.
Well, the beauty of
entrepreneurship is without,
it's inherently accountability
otherwise it fails.
I do want people to be
happy and I actually think
accountability leads to happiness.
When you think the government's in charge,
the media's in charge,
Facebook's in charge,
this boss is in charge, when
you believe somebody else
is in charge of your life, you immediately
start the process of unhappiness.
Accountability is the
framework of happiness.
It doesn't mean bad
things aren't happening,
it's not the delusion to the
macro injustices of the world.
It's called accountability.
You know, what a great
way to wrap this up.
I'm struggling not to smile very heavily.
- You can smile.
- The only reason this all matters
is everything else get
commoditized with technology
and what we will be left with
is emotional intelligence
and communication.
So, what do I want my
daughter ti be equipped with?
Self esteem that doesn't
lead to a delusion.
A self awareness radar that allows her
to know what actually makes her happy.
And for her to have incredible work ethic
out of the reality that she
found something she likes
so much that she doesn't even realize
she's working that much.
That old adage of find something you love,
you never work a day in your life
is remarkably on point.
And most people think it's baloney
except for that small percentage
that actually have found
what they're best at
and they love the most.
- And because we might
in Europe, at least,
get something what we call basic income
in a few years because
technology will do some parts
of the jobs that we're doing.
You really need to find what
you love 'cause otherwise what
are you gonna do all day?
- Yeah, and honestly,
honestly, I think basic income
and I don't know the details on this
but if you're alluding to being subsidized
because technology is taking your job,
this is where I do think that in Europe
and this is a US conversation as well.
That is where I do get concerned.
I'll tell you why.
Farming was what everybody did.
150 years ago, 100 years ago, we farmed.
Everybody.
And then machines came
along and we didn't need you
to pick the corn.
The machine picked the corn.
We didn't in 1930, 40, 50, 60 say,
oh, we're so devastated
for all the farmers.
The farmers found different jobs.
If we are now saying as
a society of 7.7 billion,
hey, we're gonna subsidize a
portion of this transition,
you're starting to already
create that level of entitlement
and lack of accountability.
I hear this all the time.
Gary, what are we gonna
do about all the drivers
driving trucks and cars?
In the US it's one of the biggest
- The self driving cars and trucks
- Right, I go, if you're a
driver in the world right now,
for the last 36 months,
the amount of coverage
that we've had that
driving's gonna be obsolete.
If you're a 27 year old
truck driver right now
and you aren't planning
on what you're gonna do
about autonomous cars,
we have to ask ourselves
where do we hold people
accountable for their actions
to adjust to the realities of the world?
And not that I have the right answer
because my answer earlier was employee,
employee 50 50 and maybe what
Sweden or Europe is doing
is actually right.
Maybe there does need to be
some small version of subsidies.
But we need to be very thoughtful
that we don't put human being
in a level of entitlement
because as soon as that happens,
we get into a world of non action.
And that becomes a very
difficult place to be.
- Finally, you know we're on a mission
to raise the level of
engagement in organizations
starting in Sweden and our goal
is to create a global movement.
If you were the minister of
engagement in the government,
what would you focus on so,
more people can go to work
because they want to and not
because they're forced to?
- I would focus on heavy investment in
modern communication tactics
across 20 to 15 meaningful
platforms like YouTube,
podcasts, Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat, on and on and
I would pump information
literal and gray around
this subject matter.
Comms is how you change things.
Not laws, not mandates, communication
to change the heart and minds of everyone.
So I would pour almost all of my money
into modern communication tactics
to bring awareness
around this issue itself.
- Thank you so much Gary for joining in
- Thank you.
- (mumbles), well done.